now a couple of things i need to um take
some notes on okay um i was i was very
sort of on detail when we were talking
about introducing matrices because i
didn't want you to get caught up in
language too quickly okay but what
you're looking at what we started
talking about they're not just matrices
okay they're actually called
augmented matrices
augmented matrices okay the reason
they're called augmented is because see
that line down the middle right well not
quite down the middle but
in that section there right
it really means you've got two matrices
and they've just been jammed together
right
and i'm just doing all the same
operations to everything okay so there's
the first thing uh it's really an
augmented matrix i don't have to have an
augmented one right i could just write
for instance
down the bottom there in the bottom left
hand corner i could have this
this
zero zero one which would mean
that's still a matrix
right
and then i can put it together with
another one
negative tuning in two
and four right
it's the same thing but i'm just kind of
trying to save a bit of time and a bit
of space okay so instead of having these
two brackets i put them together there
you go okay
all right now secondly i want you to
look back over the operations that we
wrote down okay let me zoom out a little
bit so you can see a few more hopefully
you can still read those that's enough
okay
have a look at the operations we did a
whole bunch of them lots of different
variants on them there are really only
three things you can do
i'm going to call these row operations
okay and i want you to make the same
subheading as well
one two
three
okay
there are only three things you can do
really i'll give you the first one for
free because i didn't really do it in
this case okay
you tell me why i can do this i'm gonna
try and work this as simple as i can
one of the operations you can do
is you can swap rows if you want to okay
what would swapping rows signify in the
original question
about a's and b's and c's
if i were to swap row two and row three
for instance or row one and row two what
would it mean to do that
yeah
okay right so in case i want to um have
the positives subtract the negatives or
vice versa or whatever or big numbers
take away little numbers okay it's just
the position thing i guess up here it
would mean instead of saying equation
one equation two equation three
i just label them differently maybe i
want this one to be one and this one two
and this one three or whatever okay
that's a simple thing
what are the other kinds of operations
that we did very very simple any takers
for the second one
it's good
you can add
um
rows now
i'm gonna i'm not even gonna say
subtract really because subtraction is
just adding in reverse is that okay
right so you can add rows or you can add
negative rows right
you don't just get to be able to add
rows though either you can also have a
look at this line here
this one
oops not the whole thing just that right
in that case i added a multiple of a row
right
so i'm going to say
now
i'm going to put some words here which
you might not understand what they mean
but let's tease it apart
okay
right
so you're like
it started off pretty simple why'd you
make it all confusing let's think about
it okay adding rose we get that right um
no prizes for guessing what does
non-zero mean
any things that's not zero okay i have a
question for you think about it
what would be missing what would change
if i didn't have that phrase there
i'll let you think about at the end of
the lesson i'll tell you the answer
unless someone can work it out okay
because this phrase is actually
important
you can add non-zero now scala what does
that mean for our intents and purposes
it just means numbers
okay now you're thinking what else can
you multiply by if not by numbers and
the answer is
stay tuned for the next lesson okay now
scalar and then multiples you know what
those are okay so i could multiply i
could add
3 times row 1 or 2 times row 1 or 1
times row 1 and so on okay but you can't
multiply rows
by zero y
you have to think about it then
everything equals zero
zero well okay but so what that's
so what is my question i'll let you have
a think about it okay
there's one more thing i can do
have a look
yeah well and division is really just
backwards
multiplication isn't it so i'm just
going to say multiply
rows
by and i'm going to say the same thing
right
none
zero
numbers okay
we'll tease we'll tease out exactly why
i'm introducing this weird word um in
the next week or so okay